et l'homme a grippé et les mains dans 12
210 quand même assez basses assez
envahissant pour quelqu'un qui est mon
supérieur et l'archevêque de québec
cette femme qui souhaite protéger son
identité était agente de pastorale
stagiaires ou diocèse de québec entre
2008 et 2010 à plusieurs occasions le
cardinal ouellet tu aurais posé des
gestes inappropriés à son endroit ça
allait comme un peu en gradation on
augmenta c'était de plus en plus
envahissant de plus en plus intense
massage des épaules caresses dans le dos
jusqu'aux fesses étreintes embrassades
des contacts intrusif qui la rendait mal
à l'aise j'avais l'impression des fois
qu'il me pourchassait au point où je me
suis mis à arrêter aux événements
essayer d'éviter plus possible d'être en
sa présence elle est aujourd'hui une des
requérantes de l'action collective
autorisés contre le diocèse de québec et
tous ces propos coïncide avec le contenu
de la requête entre autres lorsqu'elle
ose parler de son malaise on répond que
le cardinal et chaleureux et qu'elle
n'est pas la seule femme à avoir ce
genre de problème avec lui un homme
chaleureux un autorités comme il l'était
à l'époque ses proches à l'heureux selon
un des avocats qui est temps que le
recours les gestes reprochés au cardinal
ouellet pts peuvent sembler moins grave
que ceux posés par d'autres mais ils ne
doivent pas être banalisé c'est pas le
nom mais c'est pas le type d'agression
qui est important c'est les conséquences
les séquelles et c'est ça qu'il faut
évaluer il est difficile d'imaginer
qu'une personne de son intelligence dans
un puits seulement dans laquelle il est
qu'ils pouvaient pas ignorer ce qu'il
faisait et les conséquences sa part à la
jeune femme ne faisait pas dénoncer son
patron petitesse celui qui au bout de
mes deux ans de stage allait signer ou
non mon contrôle comme mandaté comme
agent de pastorale vous avez là à ce
moment là une jeune femme ils ont omis
21 verset un homme puissant notorité
connu mondialement n'est pas qu'ils
avaient peut-être 60 1 est le figé comme
beaucoup de victimes comme la majorité
des victimes est love figé les incidents
pris fin en 2010 lorsque marc wallet est
rappelé à rome est nommé préfet de la
congrégation pour les évêques c'est
après avoir vécu une expérience
éprouvante et impliquant un deuxième
prêtres que la requérante contacter le
comité conseil du diocèse de québec pour
les abus sexuels en 2020 j'ai abordé le
comité un peu en leur disant ben je sais
pas si j'ai été victime mais voici mon
petit trot et j'avais senti besoin de
relater tout ce que j'avais vécu
d'inapproprié depuis mes débuts comme
agent de pasteur alors exposés aux
situations sans les nommer aux comités
conseils et comités conseils du diocèse
albou de 2 d'un certain nombre de tares
du oui c'est une agression sexuelle et
c'est là qu'elle est dû aux qualités
conseil c'est cardinal ouellet la
plainte envers le cardinal wallet se
rend directement à rome et les confier
au père jacques servait une rencontre
par visio conférence a lieu avec
l'émissaire du vatican un an plus tard
la plaignante attend toujours ses
conclusions le diocèse de québec dit
prendre acte des allégations à l'endroit
du cardinal ouellet tu mets qu'il ne
fera strictement aucun commentaire ici
sylvie fournier radio canada montréal